each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so thank you all very much for coming
both in the room and people watching
online it's with great pleasure for me
to introduce miss Resnick miss Resnick
is known far better to most of you than
to me but I certainly have read of him
he's very prolific he was responsible
for the early effort around making
programming accessible through
mindstorms and then through scratch
which he'll talk about today and he
comes from the MIT Media Lab so let's
welcome miss Resnick thank you okay
thanks a lot it's great to be here and
it's nice to be here for a few days
because I think there are a lot of
connections between the work that we're
doing and some of the things going on
here at Microsoft and look forward to
exploring ways that we might have
further collaborations as John mentioned
I'm talking today about some of the work
we've been doing on a project we say
called scratch which is an effort to
make programming more accessible more
meaningful more social and really an
effort to democratize program it to make
programming for everyone and I know
there are a lot of efforts these days
one of the reasons people look into
making programming for everyone is
because of some of the concerns about
not enough people going into computer
science as a discipline and and
preparing to become computer science
professionals under that's one of the
concerns here and although of course
we'd like our work to play some role on
that in fact our main motivation is not
for preparing people to grow up and
become computer science professionals
but rather exploring ways to make
programming and Express a medium for
everyone even people that never imagined
themselves as programmers but to see
this something where they really can use
to express themselves to be able to
think more creatively and to just be
able to use is a new tool for expression
a variety of ways to start let me just
show you an example of a type of project
that was done by one of the young people
who's been using scratch so there's a
project that was done by a 13 year old
girl for her code name
named her screen name in the scratch
committee is Maho Ashley and now Ashley
really enjoyed making anime so she was
always great at drawing anime but she'd
never done any program we should do lots
of different images but someone
introduced her to scratch and she saw
that she can make her anime come alive
so let me show you to some examples of
the type of things that she started
working on so this is one of the
projects that she created and then
uploaded to the scratch website which he
first started making these projects and
putting them up there the scratch
website is a website think of it Someone
Like You Tube weird but instead of
putting up videos you put up your
scratch projects that you programmed and
as she put up her you know scratch
projects on the website a lot of people
really liked you know the things that
she was creating steward right very
encouraging comments ask her how did you
do that encouraging her for more so she
started putting up projects every week
sort of like a TV show in fact this
project it doesn't have the title on but
this was episode one of season two in
fact it was recapping some of the things
that happened in season one so she'd
fill up the whole following for the
different projects that she did these
you know anime soap operas that she was
creating online but in fact the thing
that got me especially interested in the
work that she was doing was not just
these weekly animations that she was
putting up the website but she kept on
you know enhancing them with new
characters and new storylines and then
at one point she put up a different sort
of project rather than just printing up
another episode with a new character she
put up the following project which in
fact was asking other people to design a
character for her weekly shows so it
says design izumi kuz sister and he
gives some different examples must have
red or blue hair how's that cut you know
you know cat horns or ram horns she's
explained what you want the car could be
then other people could put scratch
projects with their characters and she
was going to select the character and
into her further episodes so in some
ways she's here doing type of crowd
sourcing she's making use of the
scratched online community to getting no
ideas but also involve her audience so
again she's really learning a way of
thinking which you know sort of
concomitant it on the internet these
days but for kids go up and thinking be
able to do that we saw as an important
way that she was using the site that
we'd never imagined but then there was a
next step that you know after she had
done this someone wrote a comment
underneath this and said I'd like to
enter a character but I can't draw anime
the way you do I really like the way you
draw can you show me how do you draw so
she then put up the following a new
project so this one says how to draw you
know a certain character and every time
I can I can put on the soundtrack and
every time you hit the spacebar it goes
step by step and shows how to draw how
she draws her anime characters
multivox the day
so here she was doing your own
interactive tutorials sit for me in the
space of a few weeks mahou Ashley have
been creating these you know weekly
animations she then puts a type of
online contest of getting people to
contribute and then starts making
interactive tutorials in my mind is the
type of creative thinking that we really
wanted to inspire with scratch to have
people do not just put a project really
think of whole new genres of projects
Troy let there to play out their
imaginations and be able to design
create and share things of you know
based on their own imaginations so you
know as we were developing up developing
scratch you I think we start from
beginning how is it that we can reach
out more broadly help me make this
different then obviously been a lot of
attempts in the past to try to bring
make programming languages accessible to
what much wider range of people may be
the one of the best known was from my
mentors Seymour Papert who is one of my
advisors when I was in graduate school
who developed along with others the
language logo which in the 80s got out
to many different people but then sort
of hit a plateau and never really lived
up to its dream of being a type of
language to let everybody expressed
themselves computationally at the time
was using a little graphic turtle to
draw drawings on the screen at the time
it film it was in tune with the times
but his computer power advanced and
people started using appears for more
things it started to feel like it didn't
keep up with the times and it really was
no longer a tool to let everybody
express themselves and right now I think
there aren't tools like that the way
that logo was in the 80s to allow
everybody to really create their own
dynamic interactive content I mean we
hear a lot these days about web 2 2 2
point 0 and lots of people contributing
things but they usually aren't
contributing dynamic interactive content
people contribute text and photographs
and even video but generally not dynamic
interactive content I think that's
really missing out on something what we
really want to do is democratize the
creative dynamic interactive content and
thinking how we could do this we saw
three of the things we needed to do
was to make it more accessible more
meaningful more connected what you're
really interested in and more social so
it's connected with other people so let
me show you a little about how you use
scratch start out with some of the
things we did to make it more accessible
to make it easier for people to be able
to start creating projects well so
here's the scratch screen starts with
this character the scratch cat if we're
gonna make the scratch cat move I can
pull the block that says move 10 steps
we're going to double click on it the
cat moves if I want to make it play a
sound that it's moving I can just pull
it go the sound category pull out a
block that says play drum choose an
example maybe a cymbal sound if I snap
them together just like Lego bricks and
now moves and plays a sound if I want to
go backwards I could just move minus ten
steps so kids are just start playing
with numbers in a pretty natural way
let's have a play a different sounds as
it goes backwards a hand clapping sound
put them all together we have a little
dance if I wanted to keep dancing I can
just take a forever block and those
there's a space the middle so it's
suggestively shaped did indicate
something should go inside so it's just
dragging a few blocks together I've
already create a little program that
would continuously make my cat dance
without any syntax without worrying
about where's the semicolon square
brackets and one of the ways to make it
more accessible is just getting rid of a
lot of that syntax to make it said
things only fit together in ways that
are going to make sense so you can then
you add other characters if you want to
i can add in other images what kids will
often do is what I did here I've made a
picture of myself grab the photograph
myself put it in here and then I can do
various things I could here's a command
it does a type of image manipulation as
you would see in photo
shop so I can choose a different image
filter like here's the world filter so I
click that it whirls the photograph so
you can distort it but of course since
this is in a programming language I can
make it interactive so I could say
something like I want to set the amount
that it swirling now go into sensing
category I'll say to the exposition of
the mouse I don't want to do that
forever so you want to keep on setting
the amounts whirling based on the x
position the mouse so you see nails I
move the mouse back and forth I can roll
my face around so very easily I make a
interactive application which typically
is very difficult to make a little
interactive you know things like that
online if you're just putting a few
blocks together I can do it even while
it's going whether our goals to make it
more accessible is also making it what
we call more tinker ball so one of our
goals was tinker ability because we feel
for a lot of times with computer science
and computer programming is taught in
schools it's on this very planning
oriented way come up with a plan develop
your plan your goals each of the things
you need to do then finally you write
the code and try it out that works ok
for some problems for some people there
are a lot of people if that's not what
comes naturally to them they'd rather
start experimenting trying things out if
it knew if it works then you'll make it
if it doesn't work make a modification
try something different tinkering with
things as you would tinker with Lego
bricks is your building is you as kids
build with Lego bricks they don't as
they come up with a whole diagram of how
they're going to build a house they
start putting blocks together change
their plans that goes on we want to
encourage that with programming as well
so again to make a tinker but even as
this program is running I could even
you'll pull out other things let's say I
want to also you know i'm going to set
the color based on the y position of the
mouse so up and down changes color go
this way at Worlds go diagonally it does
both so it's very easy to just keep on
playing with code sharing code and
trying things out in easy ways also even
just the fact that over here know
somebody here I have a block that's no
longer being used is just sitting there
is there like on your physical desktop
you have things you have some papers
you're reading there are other papers in
a pile you're not using right now too
often when people are programming they
have to have a file
is only the code that's going to run
here we want to have it more to support
tinker ability you want to have things
around you might use later I don't need
that right now i'll put it aside so we
really try to design the software for
that type of tinker ability and
accessibility let me so I think you know
we can see that the software makes it
easier to get started with things we
also know that it's not just a matter of
making it easy in fact most people
aren't as I into doing things they're
easy what they want do it they won't do
things they care about but I think
that's a misconception oftentimes and
doing things with kids people say oh
let's just make it easy for kids most
kids don't want things easy they're
willing to work very hard at things if
they care about it so we wanted to make
sure that kids can make things with
scratch they really care about so the
example were our bird on my own
photograph kids want to bring in things
that they're familiar with from the
world so they can you grab different
images bring it in working a big variety
of different projects the way that mahou
Ashley did whether it's make your own
animation or a contest or tutorial we
want to make things you can do lots of
different things with but once one way
we think about that is again my mentors
seymour papert used to talk about
developing software with a low floor and
a high ceiling making meaning that it's
easy to get started you can keep doing
more and more complex things with that
and i think that's a good goal one thing
we've paid a lot of attention to with
scratch is what we call wide walls it's
not good enough to have things they're
easy to start with and do and do more
complex things with it yet that multiple
pathways of entry lots of different ways
of using the software because we know
the people out there have lots of
different interest there's a great
diversity of interests and we want to
make sure that the scratch can support
that diversity of projects that match up
well with the great diversity of
interest that people have so that's what
we mean by wide walls to open up to
people can do lots of different things
with scratch and the things that they
are really going to care about well just
you know show some examples that's also
a reason why we made sure that you know
scratch supported lots of media
different you know photographs images
sound music again with the demographic
we're trying to reach we're tryin to go
especially for age
eight to 16 I'll come back later about
who is is it's using scratch we knew
that you know kids do of that age do a
lot with manipulating media they love to
manipulate media of different ways so
when to make sure there was easy to
program media in a variety of different
ways I'll show you like an example
here's a project it was done by this is
one of the early project that went up on
the scratch website when we first
started the website was two years ago
may 2007 we open up the website this is
one of the first project that came in
was from a girl in Germany who made this
now you think you'll see that she's able
to mix together lots of different media
so I shall put in a full screen mode so
again she can you put in your own voice
putting your own graphics putting your
own photographs in this case you program
so I can move the be with the arrow keys
i'm here the arrow keys so again she's
make a whole new look you know story
game where i have to go and try to find
the key to get the grasshopper I'll
decay I'm given clues along the way so
again the thing is to see here is that
she was able to bring in you know none
of you none of these graphics or
photographs came with scratch but she
was able to grab photographs make her
own graphics with us with a pain editor
we have recorder own voice that's a big
way of making examinable to bring your
own things into the project you don't
just want to be programming other
people's stuff you want to program your
stuff and that's a big part of what we
want to do with scratch let me just show
one more example but she said she was 14
and a lot of these we just don't know
but you've reported as being 14 here's
an example from this is one that was
done up again by another girl there's
about the same age on where the exact
age but in the early
actually this was a variation of this
was done by a boy one of the computer
clubhouses there's there's a network of
after school learning centers we helped
start for young people from low-income
communities and that was one of the
first place where we tried out scratch
where was under development so actually
was in development he was working on a
project similar to this it wasn't this
exact project but a project like this
this is a type of game you can see when
i started the big fish follows the mouse
so I'm moving the big fish by moving the
mouse my goal is to try to eat the
little fish I'm not doing a very good
job I feel Sarah okay so he was doing
like this but then he wanted to keep
score when I was visiting he showed me
you know his project that was like this
is it but I want to keep score how can I
keep score so I showed them that there's
a category here called variables if I go
there I can make a variable I'll call it
score notice that puts a little readout
here with the score and creates some
blocks over there for setting the score
changing the score I showed him how I
could drag out the change score by one
block and when I click it it changes the
score by one and he immediately saw if
you just put that block in the program
where the big fish eats the little fish
then the score will go up by one every
time the big fish eats the little fish
it does so we saw that and he reached
out his hand to me he said thank you
thank you thank you and what went
through my mind is I wonder how often
algebra teachers get thanked by their
students for teaching the variables and
it doesn't happen very often I think the
reason is it's usually not introduced in
a way that's so meaningful so again our
goal is make sure you introduce things
to kids in a way that's meaningful let
them bring their world into it through
different media introduce activities
that they care about is a big way in
which we're doing this and if I can oh
they're different choices to make on
this and again and it's not this
necessary right or wrong choice the
different ways of doing in fact just to
point out you know probably the language
that scratch is most similar to his
hours from Carnegie
which is you which is inspiring in many
ways they made a different choice with
this by going with 3d graphics it's
inspiring to a lot of kids because you
know again they see lots of 3d graphics
and games so they can control some 3d
objects is one way of making things
meaningful we made explicitly a very
different choice one problem with going
with 3d graphs is it's hard to bring
your own things into the world so
there's this trade-off between have
these very you know beautiful
sophisticated graphics did you get to
control or bring your own things in
there it aren't nearly as you know
richly you know designed but designed it
personally of yours so with with scratch
replacing the bet that there are a lot
of people who really want bring their
own things into it it's not either/or
there's advantages to both but those are
some of the type of decisions we made as
we were doing the design of scratch oh
just this is from a scratch parent so
apparently runs we get messages all the
time just read it is from a parent said
I have to admit I initially didn't get
why a kids programming language should
be so media-centric but after seeing my
kids interact with scratch it became
much more clearer to me one of the
nicest things I saw was scratched was it
a personalized the development
experience in new ways by make it easy
for me kids to add personalized content
and actually participate in the
development process not only could they
develop abstract programs to do mindless
things with a cat or a box but they
could add their own pictures their own
voices to the scratch environment which
is given them hours of fun and driven
them to learn and that's exactly we're
hoping to do so it's as satisfying to us
we see that some people are using it
that way and appreciate a good now the
third component of what we want to do is
scratch was also make it more social too
often there's you know the view of
programming that I think is common for
people who don't know much about this
that is someone sitting by themselves in
front of a screen in a totally isolating
way and we know that for a lot of people
to get them engage in this activity to
be expressive with programming we want
to make it social to be able to have
where you can both share your creations
with others to see what others are doing
to collaborate on projects with each
other so for doing that right from the
beginning as soon as we introduce the
software the application we ingest a
website at the same time the two are
coupled together from the beginning it
wasn't just an add-on we developed them
in tandem with each other you know this
you know YouTube like site where you can
see the newest project that you have
uploaded featured projects so when
you're working in scratch and a predator
should have shown this notice that the
top is a save button as you would
normally expect if there's a button
there that says share at the top if you
work on a project you click the share
button and it immediately takes your
project and puts it up on the website so
makes it very easy to take your project
and share it with others so the others
can see it so there's a real motivation
we have an audience for the things that
you create but you also have a great
library of other people's work so you
can go and get inspired but what others
have done and we've seen you know the
people you spend time is they start work
on this they get to see they put their
own things up there and they get
feedback from others as other people
write comments you know on what they've
done which gives them new ideas and then
they's look around the site to see what
others have done to give them ideas you
know on what they're doing let me just
show you some of the different ways that
the website you know has been used so
i'll show some more of these projects
these are all projects that were taken
from the website there's one that just
showed before in the early days of the
web site like one thing was we started
seeing you know someone made a tetris
game like this and with the arrow keys i
can move it around and flip it around
but then not long after this was up
there some people saw this and said well
that's nice it's nice to play Ted
treasures but they're long ways this can
be proved you could add color to it out
instructions you know you know how to
look ahead so you can see what's coming
and before long we started to see other
projects like this that enhanced it in
different ways again put different types
of scoring in there right now if you go
to the scratch website there dozens of
tetris games that most of them are
coming from a few initial tetris games
that people just keep remix and remix
saying on the scratch website there now
nearly 350,000 projects they've gone up
there and where the 50,000 of them are
remixes mean to
well it took someone else's project
change the code and put up there so it's
a real open source community where
people are taking other people's code
remix in it either changing the code
changing graphics and putting it back up
there at first it led to a lot of
complaints that kids would say someone
stole my project but of course that was
good discussion to have do it then say
no part of the culture of the scratch
community is that the idea is you should
share things with each other and then we
put things in the Scottish me you should
be a proud of somebody's using some of
your code you should also of course if
you take someone else's code give
acknowledgement and people you know
sometimes people do but they didn't
always give acknowledgement so then we
updated the website so we keep track of
this now where we keep track of if you
download a project make a change to it
when it's uploaded you know when it's
when it's posted on the website they'll
say so and so's project based on a
project by and you can see the whole
lineage of it so you can see where it
came from so with these tetris games you
can see I what traces back and where it
came from and then actually to encourage
that behavior on the homepage one of the
categories we put was top remixed
project so if your project got remixed
by other people it ended up on the
homepage so as a source of pride to be
remixed more than other people so again
part of the way we design the site is
also to encourage certain types of ways
of thinking about your activity on this
site and certain ways of thinking about
collaboration and sharing I see i lost
the tetris game while I was talking now
we expected it would be things like
Tetris when we made the when we moving
made scratch I'll show you a few things
now that took us by surprise the next
one took us by surprise just because of
its sophistication as we were developing
the software we never imagined that
someone really could do a fairly true
version of Donkey Kong using it but it's
a pretty good version so the first thing
that amazed us was oops you're just how
sophisticated people could get you using
the software that we had given them so
people really used it to do much more
sophisticated things than than what we
anticipated and again and again we were
surprised by the sophistication but
maybe
more rewarding test was not the
sophistication but the diversity of
projects in the different ways that
people thought about collaborating that
we never imagined so here's an example
this was done by a girl in England I
think she was about 12 years old and she
put up a project that all it had were a
bunch of different simple animated
characters and with this project in the
project notes she said I didn't really
like making games or stories I just like
making characters if you like my
characters please use them in your games
or stories and give me credit she said
if you want a different type of
character leave a note below and I'll
make a character for you so she was
opening up a type of consulting service
on the scratch website and in fact sure
enough she started to get requests so
here's a project that was done by a girl
in Russia who asked for a certain type
of project if you see the style here I
think of recognizing in this game so
this character was made
and here again there's one of these
games where you can move the character
if I go to the stove I can eat and get
more food and get energy if I walk
outside had to be careful not to fall
down so before long there were four
different kids working on these games
they started a whole company that they
called it crank inc that the four of
them did they started posting notes
about who they needed for cranking and
there was a kid from New Jersey was a
good programmer join them and someone
else was good at graphics someone else
had scrolling backgrounds that they
could do so he came in so again they
started to go and kids and difficulties
it like it was for kids in three
different countries who are working
together on these projects on the
website an addition is creating projects
they start to use the website as a way
of communicating among themselves so
like when one of them had a birthday one
of the kids in the group put up this
project so the birthday card for Sonic
pops was the screen name for one of the
kids of who is making the games so again
just using once you put a medium out
there what we'd hope was that people
would find all sorts of different ways
of using it and sure enough it was
happening
and there are lots of other ways that
people then started communicating to
others in the community here's one of my
favorite examples was one kid put up
this project that he called SNN for
scratch news network and you see the cat
there is giving some news about the site
because the lego coming donated some
images for the web sites could then be
used in your scratch project this is
giving news about the new things
happening on the scratch website and
when I first saw this I thought that's
cute it's a simulated newscast and then
I stopped myself and I said this is not
a simulated newscast this is a newscast
is reaching a real community is somebody
giving news to a real community this is
a real newscast and he do he would have
these regular your newscast about what's
happening on the scratchiness no
unlimits scratch website and soon there
are a lot of copycats their newsletters
and TV shows where people are saying
your people doing reviews you know so
it's a news niall weekly newsletter with
the reviews of their best you know what
they think of the best projects of the
past week there are a lot of different
ways the people that are using it to
communicate with each other another type
of communication the next one is one
where people start pre on projects to
give it advice to others so this was one
about giving advice of how to get your
project more popular on the scratch
website so they could get featured on
the homepage of scratch take time of
your project to make it a decent project
that way people are more likely going to
love your project to love your product
means you can click I love it and that
shows up in the homepage baguette allah
loves friends then you more rightly
gonna have people to love your project
step-free i do project to a gallery so
then when people are searching through
other people's galleries they'll find
your project step 4 put your project
sandra pop your tag and then more people
are going to find it when they're going
for the most popular tags so again you
get the idea so again people are clearly
learning you know some things about how
to how to work on a social networking
site
and you how to do it and surf sharing
those ideas with each other I also like
this sort of a nice simple minimalist
design it's just his voice a nice little
note simple you know the other time on
it so you know again they're really
learning about ways of expressing
themselves in this you know through this
new medium there's also you know
although we started out the Midas older
men when we started out a lot of Lee
when scratch first came out in 2007 was
used most of my kids at home and some
after-school centers but over the past
year it's started to get used more and
more in schools as well so when show a
few projects how it started to get used
in schools this is a project that was
done at a school in India where we have
a collaboration in bangalore as
disclosed just mentioned to bill i was
here from bangalore this is a project
where they've been studying the
different layers of the earth and after
studying it he then made this sort of
animated story where he talks about
what's happening at the different layers
of the earth so again he's speaking his
native language of canada as he goes
down you'll see these nails sort of go
is there a tour as he goes down explains
what's happening at different places
it's great we get to the water table
there's some nice sound effects of
hitting the water so in some way through
using this the way that in many schools
they use powerpoint today but this gives
them new different capabilities of being
able to add more dynamic interactive
things in a different way so it's on
where this tool can be used in many
different ways it's not just about you
know in your computer literacy or
computer science course you can use this
for writing your book report your social
studies report just different ways of
telling about the things they're
learning it communicated here's one that
was done for social studies classes by a
boy in the United States we're studying
the island of Rapa Nui Easter I'll off
of South America and at the end of the
unit you want they were supposed to
write up something about the local what
they learn about the local economy in
the local culture so he made a little
simulated world in the spirit of SimCity
and again you can use the arrow keys to
move the character around in this case I
know if I go the tree
I can cut down a branch I get it I
thought I can get a branch of their to
make a fishing rod and that can go and I
can catch fish and I get fish I can get
you know I can contribute to local
economy so his way of creating this to
show what he had learned about the local
economy and culture of Rapa Nui but also
to engage other people to express his
ideas to communicate with others so it
really is trying to often school reports
are just on you have to do and only the
teacher reads that here was something he
was doing to really communicate with
others I'll show one last example this
is in a science class so someone did a
science project where it was about
testing a reaction time say Papa project
and it says when the color turns hit the
stop and what does is it times how
quickly hit the stop after the color
changes so it keeps it collects data
about how quickly people do this and
then it asks them different questions
about how old are you what sports do you
play how much do you weigh and then try
to do different types of correlations
between age and reaction time or what
sports you playing reaction time so
again this is a type of project someone
could have done as a science fair
project with the kids in their class but
he was able to do it with kids all
around the world and get you know what's
wider range much larger amount of data
and much more diverse set of data by
leveraging the capabilities you know of
the website so I thought I hope you see
from those examples the rich range of
things that are happening the website
which again was to us one of the most
rewarding things this mean we had this
goal of wide walls major pathways to
entry because we know that people are
going to find most meaningful if they're
able to do things they care about so I
think the examples to usher that there
really was this you know rich collection
of possibilities that people are able to
do and also was able to bring in kids
who especially interred in the social
dimension of sharing their project with
others again different kids get
attractive for different reasons some
just enjoy that the you know the
excitement of solving the problem others
want to house know where there's an
audience where they get feedback from
the audience so this neighbors want to
collaborate with others on their
projects this opens up to all those
different possibilities so it's now
become a very active and vibrant online
community every day
every day on the scratch website now
there's more than a thousand new
projects every day that come up to the
website and so as I said they're more
than three about 350,000 projects now
there's still a lot of challenges I was
talking to some people before right now
we don't do such a good job of giving
tools to find projects that you'd be
interested in yeah there's standard
tagging and some other ways of doing it
I think there's a lot more we condone
the website tell people be able to find
project they're interested in find
people they'd be interested in
collaborating with so as many things
we're still working on and trying to do
that here's just a histogram of the ages
of people who register for the website
any of these are self-reported ages we
assume they're correct the peak is at
age 12 so that you know the main peak is
between age 8 and 16 so it's really the
age we aim for is the age that you know
we have most of it I think this is an
artifact I think that's no something
where the I think is the age that was
set back like 1980 or something so it's
something that is if somebody doesn't
fill then it shows up there you can see
there's a fairly long tail especially
people in their 20s these are probably
some parents or teachers but there's
also a fair number of people were just
using it as hobbyists if they want to
send a birthday interactive birthday
card to a friend they use scratch make
an interactive card with a picture and
then talking and then send it to a
friend so there's a fair amount of use
even with adults even though our main
goal was breathing out the 8 to 16 your
old age range there just again a quote
from a 13 year old girl who started one
of these companies who worked with other
kids are making games there's a company
called blue elk and said what's fun
about scratch about organizing a company
to write games together is I've made a
lot of friends learn lots of new things
I've learned a lot about different kinds
of programming by looking at other games
and with interesting effects downloading
them and looking at modifying the
scripts and sprites I really like
programming also when i started with
scratch i didn't think i was a very good
artist but since then just by looking at
other people's art asking the questions
practicing drawing using programs like
photoshop and scratch painter I've
gotten a lot better at art again we like
the fact the kids are both programming
doing things with art and by working at
it starting to feel differently
their capabilities with us another
things I've learned while organizing
blue l is how about but keep a group of
people motivated and working together we
could all learn to you all need to learn
a little more about that a leg scratch
better than blogs or social networking
sites like Facebook because we're
creating interesting games and projects
that have fun to play watch and download
I don't like to just talk to other
people online I like to talk about
something creative and know so again we
have some kids who want to be there
because they want to work with other
kids and express themselves working on
creative projects and still was happy
that you need more out more place for
kids to do that more ways to encourage
kids to be able to do that I think as
kids work on scratch they're going
through a we sometimes called the
creative learning spiral and what we
think that some of the best learning
happens we could start with imagination
they have an idea of what they want to
do but just imagining it is not enough
you didn't have to create something
scratch less than you make it that
program the different I've interactive
story you can then play with it an
experiment with it you can interact with
the things you've created you share with
others on the scratch website other
people then get feedback on it based on
the comments you get on the website it
leads you to reflect you think about how
could I have done this differently that
was a good idea maybe I'll add this
other feature and that lets you imagine
new ideas so we see kids on the website
going around and round in this creative
learning spire which we see is some of
those you know richest approaches to
learning it's exactly what we're hoping
to support in getting scratch out there
and his kids go around this creative
learning spiral I think what we see them
doing is we see them like to think
creatively like mahou Ashley come up
with many different genres of things
that they're a dim types of projects or
creative ways of solving problems they
learn to reason systematically you know
we tried to make the blocks as ease of
use as possible getting rid of this
syntax but there's still a lot of
careful reasoning that needs to be done
kids need to analyze a reason carefully
in order to make their programs work and
they need to work collaboratively on the
website to get ideas from one another
and different ways of collaborating that
weren't even possible ten years ago kids
are learning on the website so this is
our real goal is to see how we can help
kids think creatively reason
systematically work
operatively because we think those are
some of the most important skills to
have for the 21st century no matter what
you grow up to be and also in your work
life or in your personal life or in your
civic life in your community these are
skills they're going to be really
important to having a successful life in
a satisfying life and that's what we
want to support with scratch another
dimension that we think kids are
learning is what's come to be called
computational thinking learn some core
ideas about computation you're just the
idea of an algorithm what it means to
describe process what it means to
simulate to model there's core ideas
about computation are things they learn
as they start making even relatively
simple projects with scratch and I think
it's important to ask you why
computational thinking as I said in the
beginning we have some particular
reasons why we are very interested a lot
of people want to support computational
thinking and bring you to have more kids
learn to be computational thinkers to
prepare more computer science
professionals and that's a worthy goal
and I think that's one good thing that
can come of it I must need a lot of our
motivation of scratch was not just with
that but also to enable personal
expression we want people to be able to
express themselves to give everyone a
voice to let people use the media of the
day to be able to express themselves we
don't want people to just be pointing
clicking interacting we want everyone to
have a voice we want people to be able
to design create and invent not just
browse click and chat to enable creative
thinking in the ways we talked about to
enable learning of other things as you
work with scratch and learn the
computational ideas it helps you learn
other things as kids do models of we
have kids doing a model of the cell so
they're learning programming but they're
learning other things through the
programming activities and finally
preparing responsible citizens I mean
just to be a citizen of today's society
one needs to be able to think of these
computational ideas too often when
people try in schools to help engage
kids in computational thinking in my
mind it too often is done by saying
here's a list of concepts you should
know I want you it's important to learn
these concepts and yes they're important
concepts i think is we think about
computational thinking we think a lot
about what are the pathways
as we develop scratch we thought what
are the ways to get people engaged it's
not just a matter of what we want kids
to learn but what are the ways to engage
them in learning those things so what no
what we did we've tried to support
personal connections as I explained put
yourself into your project let kids work
on projects they gave your deeply about
support social connections let them
learn along with others to connect ideas
to activities it's not enough just to
say these are the important concepts
concepts are learn best when they're
embedded in meaningful activities so we
always think about the activities not
just the concepts reach me on
problem-solving oftentimes the school
people say we have to teach
problem-solving skills yes
problem-solving is important but
designing creating and expressing
yourself is important as well a lot of
the line that goes on shouldn't be just
help solve a problem that someone's
given you but how to express yourself to
create things to design things a big
part of what we do in our lives a big
part of what you all do here in your
jobs is not just solving a problem that
someone gave you but coming up with the
design that's going to satisfy some
situation that has arisen so this is
what we're trying to do with scratch to
satisfy these approaches to have young
people grow up as computational thinkers
I would say a few words about some of
the future directions that we're going
with scratch right inhale a lot of the
use of scratches on the screen with
examples I showed you we also want to go
off of the screen as John mentioned
earlier in some of the work I've done
over the years is I've done a lot of
work with the Lego toy company we
developed the early prototypes that led
to Lego Mindstorms other robotics kits
and we see kids learning a lot we
they're dealing with things in the
physical world kids grow up in the
physical world they have passions about
the physical world so we want to engage
them in thinking about the physical
world while they're doing things on the
screen so one way we're doing that is
through what we call the scratch board
the scratch censor board so it's a board
that connects to a USB port and then it
has a slider it also has certain sensors
its sound sensor light sensor also a
place where you can plug in and make
your own sensors so enables kids to make
projects like this so there's a project
that was done i just found this was
visiting
and after school center in Hong Kong and
they showed me this project they had
done with the scratch board so what is
is it's a project to just say it's about
slowing down a tree and they made a
physical saw see there's a hole in the
board and it's over the light sensor to
look at the light central the scratch
board and when the hole goes over the
light sensor can see the hole is over so
it can detect how they're moving this
sloth and then they control this this is
a case where kids are making their own
new physical interfaces so it's you know
they shouldn't be restricted to just
joysticks and mice let them make their
own physical interfaces again to receive
lots of ways that kids use this of
taking things in the you know you know
from the things you know sensory input
from the physical world to control
things on the screen you'll based on the
level of light in the room change things
on the screen or even with a tilt sensor
use a laptop and then actually as you
move it have that the tilt Center
control what's happening on the screen
another direction we want to go is
reaching out more globally in the latest
version of scratch in fact when we just
show this you notice that there's a
button here called language I can choose
you know for a wide range of different
languages so if i choose like this is he
bro you're my project will then show up
in he bro so basically if a kid in
boston wrote that project in england in
english i put up on the website and then
a kid in tel aviv you know downloaded it
they could then see it in hebrew make
changes upload it and could be
transferred back and forth so since
almost all the words are based on you
know these blocks is quite easy just
change from one language to another we
now support our things close to 50
languages also we did these 50 languages
without paying a penny tiny translates
it's an open source project we just you
know there's no worldwide community we
put up a we use a website that supports
this we just ask people to fill the
spreadsheet there are few hundred word
and phrases in scratch we just had
people put up and there's a place for
discussion gob viously people have your
differences of opinion between what word
should be used at first we thought we
could just have one Portuguese version
but it has to be a Brazilian Portuguese
version of Portuguese Portuguese version
just out there's a French Canadian
version of French version but no people
have discussion about what words we
should use for different things and then
we support them all you know in the in
the interface we also started to put up
the website the website right now we're
still trying to figure out what to do
with this even though you can change the
language you know and there's in the
application to any language you want
most of the comments on the website are
in English and most of discussion of the
discussion forums are in English so
we're experimenting now just last month
português portugal telecom of the main
telecom company in portugal worked with
us to put up their own scratch website
and we gave them a special version of
scratch doing kids in portugal hit the
share button rather than the project to
probe their project uploading to the
server mit it uploads to a server at
portugal telecom and shows up on their
webpage and the discussion forms here
are in portuguese again their trade offs
here because right now they don't get to
see projects done by kids in China or
India or Brazil so we're trying to
figure out the best ways to satisfy both
these to be able to have some local
sharing of ideas but also be able to see
what's happening globally so we're still
experimenting on ways of doing it or
second example by the way is we have one
we work with a group in the United Arab
Emirates who's also doing a website so
again we're experimenting if these are
things we're still in the process of
learning we're making version of scratch
to go on different platforms we have
version of running on the LPC XO on the
classmate in fact I've the classmate
here we even have a virgin scratch
running all the small this small screen
class made it for each day afterwards
you can compensate i should add its with
its from support from microsoft that
made a lot of this possible that they
were drilled strong supporters and help
provide funding for doing some of the
trenton for supporting the
internationalization and bringing it to
these different platforms we're also
trying to bring into smaller platforms
tells if you comp after they're going to
show you some of the work grab with the
version of scratch running on hand
towels obvious they're big user
interface challenges they were still
working on that it would still try to
figure out the best ways of handling it
this is one of my students our crows Oh
mom did a version of scratch to control
characters in Second Life so again it's
using the same type scratch blocks but
some different vocabularies to control
objects in the 3d shared world because
right now in second life is easy to
create objects but it's really difficult
to control to create behaviors there's a
scripting language the basically need a
PhD in computer science to use and we
wanted to make it so that everyone could
be able to control behaviors in Second
Life so again this just still an early
prototype but a direction we're headed
we're doing a lot in the robotics area
NEC the Japanese company has a robot
called Papa Rao and we have a version of
scratch to control Papa Rao this used to
just be an entertainment robot or a bit
trade shows and dance around the same
things but now kids can program Papa row
themselves we're starting a website
again with support from Microsoft called
scratch add that brings to the goal is
to bring together educators who want to
share their ideas about scratch so where
is the main scratch website is mostly
for kids sharing their scratch projects
scratch ad is for educators to share
stories about scratch to share their
lesson plans or curriculum ideas about
scratch so we'll provide some ideas and
resources there we're then going to try
to bring together the community this is
in beta form nail in May we're planning
to launch scratch ad if people happen to
be interested if you write to scratch
dash edit media you can get find out
more you can be put on mailing list
about that we're also on May sixteenth
holding a day called scratch day last
summer we had a conference at MIT where
we invited people to come to MIT to
share ideas about scratch and it sold
out a month ahead of time we had 300
educators come and there's no and it's
sold out the conference this year rather
than how many people come to MIT about
several weeks ago we put out the word on
scratch website to say rather than come
to MIT we want everyone out there to
make their own scratch event all on the
same day on May 16 I just grabbed this
last night from the website so you can
eat just in the first few weeks there's
always a pretty already a pretty big
range of places that are offering
scratch day activities it's one of the
things we're also in my visit here I'm
going to talk with some of the folks
from Microsoft about different
partnerships we might have for
organizing scratch day events to spread
the ideas and to bring people together
because on the website we get lots of
questions about that people say they
like scratch and they want to meet other
local scratchers but they don't know
where they are so this is a way to try
to bring together local people because
for all the advantages of a virtual
worldwide community there's still so
very important about meeting other local
people let me just end with a couple
this too long but I'll give it briefly
just some other things that people have
written to us just about doing it again
to capture some of the spirit of what
we're looking for this oness says you
know that he grew up using the logo
programming languages I've mentioned
before a tribute is early passion for
computer technology the work you did in
logo but he says a few weeks ago we
heard his nine-year-old and seven year
old sons talk about anime despite their
new game I watched them quickly learned
it was about scratch so clear they
didn't learn about from him the engineer
parent they learned about somewhere else
he watched them the combination of
social networking to scratch and
critical thinking and analytics made it
clear this is the next logo I've worked
in high tech for 16 years currently
running a global engineering
organization I've watched a succeeding
generation of college students have lost
the passion for computers those of us
from the first PC generation had too
often and so you can say only interested
in being consumers of technology not in
building it scratches breath of fresh
air so this is what we're looking for
turn everyone into creators the people
of course everyone gives so many people
interact with computers these days but
it shouldn't be about interacting it
should be about creating designing and
that's we were you know aiming for and
I'll finish with one final quote that I
got from the editor-in-chief of
communications of ACM you know the
leading Journal wrote to me a couple
months ago to ask me to write an article
about scratch which was nice it's nice
to be published there
but what I liked best was the little
anecdote he told me about how he had
learned about scratch he said that a
couple days ago a colleague of mine also
cs5 he told me how she tried to get her
ten-year-old daughter interested in
programming and the only thing that
appealed her daughter hugely was
scratched and that's exactly hope to do
we want to reach kids who hadn't
imagined themselves as programming were
turned off by a lot of other programming
approaches a lot of other programs out
there work well for some kids but don't
reach broadly our goal was to reach
broadly because the signs it should be
for everyone we really want to
democratize this idea the same way that
everyone should be able to express
themselves through writing not
everybody's going to grow up to be a
journalist or a professional writer but
everybody should learn to write just to
express their ideas we feel the same way
with programming most people won't go up
to be professional programmers like many
people in this room are but everyone
should be able to express their ideas
that's where trying to a scratch we
still fear at the beginning of this
we're excited about what we're saying we
look forward to working together with
Microsoft and others to try to engage
more and more kids around the world well
with these sorts of experiences thanks a
lot I'm happy to take some questions so
what what you imagine the path is a
scratch somebody gets enamoured and
wants to go to the next level I think
they've got to come up are they going to
be really disappointed when they see
what
well this is a topic that comes up a lot
in the scratch online forums but some
kids start to look for other things the
first thing I'd say is for some people
they don't need something beyond scratch
because they just want to make
interactive birthday cards for friends
and that's all they're going to do and
scratch is fine for that but for some
people they do want to do more scratch
you know it's it's limited in a wide
variety of ways to people might wanna go
further but we usually answer is it
depends on what it is they're interested
in because kids were really interested
in doing different types of you know you
know graphic animations and different
types of visual effects we encourage
them to try processing for people who
want to do different things with 3d
worlds we encourage Alice of for certain
other people we might suggest you know
flash and actionscript for you know
others might go to your program or
whether verte verges our basic their
different things for different people
based on what it is that they're looking
for so I don't think there's anyone
answer I do think that our hope is and
we don't have a lot of research on this
yet but we think that scratch will be a
relatively good foundation from moving
on to a lot of more traditional
environments because in some ways
scratches conservative in many ways for
a graphical programming language because
if you look at the scratch stacks of
blocks it basically is words you know
after one another in a sequence of
actions like in a text based programming
language where a lot of other graphical
languages is a much radically different
paradigm the paradigm with scratch
although we got rid of a lot of the
syntax the paradigm is pretty similar to
traditional text programming gets you
know yeah right yeah right yes the
certain things are easier you can
actually some things in scratch you can
deal with parallelism a lot easier in
scratch you put a lot of different
stacks click on them you can trigger
them to start at the same time certain
things are easier to do in scratch but i
think it's not we think it's a pretty
good foundation to help others get
started with other more traditional text
based languages but it must have a we
haven't really done Studies on that yet
but that's our what we thank ya bill so
I mean if your not exposing
equivalent textual representation to the
Grahams the people could edit well we
thought about that some it is one thing
to honor to do list on a different
project we worked on one of the robotics
projects we worked on we did that and we
had a text-based Cuchulain we found that
people didn't use it very much now it
could be partly that especially in the
robotics project there's pretty simple
programs and usually you want to go the
text when you when you have the
complexity where the visual nature to do
it becomes unwieldy so we found it
wasn't used that much there so that may
be so the one place we tried it end up
not being used much which probably turn
this off to it some I do think would be
used more in scratch because certainly
is like the donkey kong program if you
look at that it's pretty hard to read
because it's a big program and the the
visual nature of it it makes it not so
easy to read so I think it could be a
good thing to expose the text so we
haven't done that yet but I think it
could be a good direction ago yeah
composability like in terms of like if
you can you can you have the equivalent
of different files where like I have
Duncan care if it does some animation
and stuff and ease stored somewhere yeah
and then I have another thing which
composites him doing some actions the
one thing I mean there's a little bit
not as much as there might be just with
different characters you can export a
sprite and it brings with us or it
brings with it all of its code and
sounds yeah this also you can export the
whole sprite one thing we although you
can export it it's more of like it an
expert feature now we plan in a future
version the same way right now you can
share your whole project we know better
share a sprite and have the library of
sprites although we're still playing
with this um because in order to do that
a lot of times sprites do become
entangled with each other so even if you
export one in myself references to other
sprites we try to minimize that in the
language but it's hard to get rid of an
entire leg so most people don't write
code that makes it so easy to pull apart
the sprites and use them in other places
but we still think it could be useful
that's an active area of research of
what we're doing we definitely want to
explore more of that do that the
granularity for sherry we're generally
granularity for sharing is one issue
that we wanted
look out more because there's both the
project level which is what we do now
the sprite level which we support but
not so well or just sharing scripts we
don't do a very good job of that either
there should be libraries of scripts
that and better ways of looking for
different scripts or at least I guess
it's quite should we do that or should
always be buried inside of a sprite i'm
not sure but those are questions we want
to think about one of the questions i
have is the practical nature of
targeting for children to share with
each other how do you deal with
moderation PII legal concerns yeah you
know probably you know bad people on the
internet and kids etc has any of that
become a problem how much effort you
guys have to put it in moderation yeah
police yeah it's a good question and it
is a challenge and we made certain
choices which I'll say which aren't
necessary the choices for everyone with
everyone agrees with so right now with
the biggest issue that arises is for you
know some questionable you know content
that gets up there this inappropriate
inappropriate content for the site and
that does happen we've chosen to do it
of policing after the fact as opposed to
reviewing before the fact which means
that sometimes inappropriate content
does get up to the site you know you can
the whole community can flag it is
inappropriate we have a couple part time
people who spend their time taking a
look at projects to go up there and
certainly quickly look at anything
that's flagged to do it but things do go
up there and some people some we've
heard from some parents and teachers say
they don't want their children losing
this site because you can get
inappropriate content up there another
aspect of it is you can write comments
to each other one way that we avoid some
of the problems with the dangers of you
know somebody posing as someone they
shouldn't be all communications is
public there's no chatting no private
communication everything is public so
basically the text is just comments on
projects and discussions and online
forums and again that we have people who
sort of look at that and we also their
people in the community who do a lot of
policing for us of that busy
not just inappropriate it's one thing
and we have some filters for
inappropriate language the bigger thing
is trying I think the bigger challenge
is keeping a respectful culture because
you know kids of you know this age is a
this project sucks you know you know
that's stupid why do you ever do that
own and first of all it's a hard
question where do we draw the line
because it's okay for people to be
critical of each other and in to be
teasing each other a little bit where do
you draw the line and and how much
effort you put into it and then when you
draw the line when you want to stay sign
isn't appropriate how do you then help
educate so we do things where you know
we will take down comms will give
notifications to people we try to give
explanations so it's something we care
about we put a reasonable amount of time
into it and some funding into it to have
people who spend time doing it how well
it scales is an issue you know this is
the community's getting pretty big it
helps that we have volunteer moderators
we're trying to set up the people who've
just on their own started being active
commenters on the site will reach out to
them and we'll give them a title of your
scratch moderator and then we'll work
with them we'll do a little bit of
telling them how we think about this and
encouraging them to do a certain way but
I think we still a lot more that we need
to do with how we're going to handle the
scale up of that if this continues to
grow I guess one other issue is things
with licensed content which we don't do
anything of you know people put up
licensed characters so I'm puts up Bart
Simpson we don't take it down again a
lot of these questions are legally murky
these days about and I think we've set
it up and registered in a way that i
believe it's now set up that we don't
have any responsibility that we can't be
held liable except if if a major media
company comes to us say we want you to
take down this project this project this
project we will take it down but I don't
think we have any responsibilities
beyond that but again those are all
issues that are going to be floating in
there flying around yeah I was wondering
is there a freak
for say a teacher that wanna incorporate
this into a math lesson or a science
teacher a more guide for the teacher
vengefulness we're starting to work on
that fact a lot of talks with Rob back
back there is in the unlimited potential
group here and we're working together a
trying and developing some of those
right now we've developed a little bit
of that but we're planning to do much
more also we've been starting to collect
what others are doing because in the
last year more more teachers are
starting to use it and putting some of
their curriculum plans and activity
guides online so we're not aggregating
it together on this scratch ed website
and we're going to highlight what we see
is some of the best examples and then
add some of our own but it's an area
where I think there needs to be a lot
more work you know in there and buy one
thing we're just talking about earlier
today is we're to focus our efforts you
know how much to focus on again but
there many different places where this
could get used during the school day is
it for computer literacy class which
require a certain type of curriculum
materials or is it to support people
just making presentations in social
studies or English class so I think
we're exploring a variety of different
ways of supporting it so something we
see is important the new scratch head
website which I'll go live soon we'll
have that type of information we hope
just by having scratch ed website up
there it will also raise the visibility
and we'll be able to find even more
teachers posting their things but then
we want to an active effort not just for
the community to be filtering we all do
some community based filtering but also
for us to highlight things that we think
represent the type of teaching practices
that we want to support I like the idea
with the net logo that came out that
teachers were able to
simulation actually create different
things now but based on the basic
simulations that were presented right so
I was thinking along those lines yeah so
and then and this is also an issue that
right now I mentioned before there's
these with all the projects on the
website is not easy to find the project
most interested in so somewhere on the
website there's some good simulations
that people have done but it's not easy
to find them right now so I think we
need to do a better job of highlighting
ones that we think are best practices
that people might be able to use as
models Paula one question related to
education have you reached out to
computer science teachers of America or
is Steve to sort of publicize through
the formal learning channel its verses
yeah who doesn't like oh I gave you know
I gave talks about this the last cabal
any CC conferences you know sponsor st
i'm doing getting this year this T we're
giving a a big talk about we have you
know feature talk about scratch we're
doing a few workshops and we're actually
we just saw SD sent us an additional
ones we're doing they sent us a like a
half a dozen other sessions the other
people are doing about scratch so it's
starting to get out there that way we're
also having some talks just two weeks
ago I was in Washington DC for there was
a a workshop at the National Academy of
Sciences about computational thinking
and there I met people of the National
Science Foundation who are doing things
about high school computer science and
they're intrigued with scratch
especially not for the AP versions of
computer science wouldn't be right but
for the pre AP versions so we're
starting to have discussions with them a
list of how we might work together so
it's still in early stages but we're I
helped teach workshops on Palace little
slow kids
yeah it's not a good entry level or a
certain introduction of programming get
kids into it and you know it's little
higher levels this is perfect it turns a
little on the age level you've been then
oh yeah so alice is good for certain
kids it was Alice's definitely aimed at
older older kids than scratch was Scott
your aims with its own younger age yeah
it seems pretty clear that this helps
encourage collaboration and um you can
measure that previously but it seems a
lot harder to measure how does it
improve computational thinking and I
wonder if you guys besides that and also
how it improves like attitudes towards
program yeah we've not done a leg and
there's still early stages we haven't
done a lot of that we plan to do more
hope to do more hope other people do
more some of the things I think that
we're most interested in there even more
difficult to assess is creative thinking
we really do think that kids as they
work of scratch become more creative
thinkers and defining exactly we mean by
creative thinking is hard measuring what
we mean by that is hard on the other
hand just oppose it's hard to measure
doesn't mean we should steer away from
it because I think that's what we want
to make sure that we want to focus on
things that we think are very important
certainly is a computational thinking
again at this workshop we had a lot of
discussions about that you know just in
the last few weeks I think you're a lot
different points of view on that about
what it is you know that's most
important to be learning about
computation so but it's good there's an
active discussion going on now about
what it is and we have some of our views
and and we've started to look at that
about what kids again we haven't
informed about attitudes we haven't done
formal studies been this one to be
honest a lot place we see the sort of
just seems so obvious that is changing
the way kids are thinking about it
certainly it's been kids just if you
just look at the scratch website on the
forums one thing that took us by
surprise is when we start the website we
have the discussion forums we expect to
be mostly adults use in the discussion
forums and we were definitely wrong the
kids are very active user the discussion
forms and often talking about the things
that they're doing a scratch their
learning a scratch and you can just see
in the discussion forums now of course
this is a lot of self-selection the kids
are writing the discussion forums are
the most active and enthusiasts
enthusiastic user
you can definitely see that from some
kids just by reading their posts how is
just open up their eyes to see things in
new ways but we haven't done formal
studies to see how broadly does it reach
that way what range of kids does it
reach which kids is most likely to reach
are things that I think there's no need
for a lot more work to be done first
time that yeah um obviously multi touch
interfaces are becoming more and more
interesting and the costs and
technologies coming down feeling more
consumer-oriented is there any ideas of
adding those sorts of interactions to
scratch so that the kids can interact
with things in a more tangible sort of
way both on the composing inside and on
the interacting with fished the output
program we haven't really played with
multi-touch reasoning we were doing some
things with tablet versions so we're
doing some more experimenting about just
how we should change scratch so it works
well on tablets was one thing we looked
at we haven't really play with
multi-touch possibilities so I think
it's a good area to look at it's just
you know and it's come up in discussions
but we haven't done anything with it I
guess nothing we'd like to do over time
is there's only so much we can do and we
like to engage the broader community
right now the current version of scratch
is written in a verse of small talk
squeak that came from Allen case group
in fact I should make special mention of
the fact that meant to earlier a lot of
scratch was inspired by work we saw
going on in allen Kay's group based on
the squeak software they had a version
called etoys that was meant for kids and
my research group does a lot of work
with Allen's group we have a week an
annual retreat we were inspired by what
they were doing we've some ideas of how
we might do it differently and they
encouraged us use our code you know take
all of our ideas so generously supported
us in this effort as we did it so it's
based on squeak the one downside of that
is most people don't know squeak so we
make the source code freely available
I've never mentioned scratch itself is
freely available you might have gotten
that idea but it's freely available but
the source code is also freely available
but since
is written a squeak most people aren't
going to do I think with the source code
so in the next generation of scratch we
want to have we're just starting to
think about how to implement the next
one so make it easier to have a
community of people who can be
experimenting and adding to experiment
with different futures for it yeah you
can please on your language design
process how did you decide what more you
well we really tried to first I'll just
say we tried really hard to be strict
about trying to keep things out make one
general guideline we used remember i had
the diagram about low floor high ceiling
wide walls it's very hard to do all
three of those so from the beginning we
pretty much said whenever in conflict
will give hot top priority to load
flooring wide walls and will sacrifice
high ceiling so we sacrifice the high
ceiling the first version of scratch
that came out and and will only put in
features if we feel we can do it in a
very intuitive way this can be easily
understandable and we want to try to
minimize it to people don't become
overwhelmed in fact this is one of our
things as I said we were tremendously
inspired by the etoys version of squeak
we felt it was overwhelming and
confusing so even though we were
inspired but we could do with that a big
part of why we want to do scratch was
simplified the user interface shrink the
feature set keep the core things so we
first of all as we're developing we were
using with kids all the time we saw what
did kids most want to use we're also
based on us just working with we have 20
years of experience working with kids on
things like this so we had our own
intuitions about what was going to
appeal to kids we tried to be ruthless
if we if we didn't think a block was
going to get used a lot keep it out
because we want to have in each pilot to
try not to have to scroll down you still
have to do it somewhat but try to keep
it that way in the first version scratch
that came out there was only one data
type numbers because we didn't have good
ways of representing other ones we
weren't satisfied with it we're
gradually adding more so there now lists
so we have some more data structures we
just aren't introduced strings so we're
only introducing things really slowly as
we feel we have good intuitive visual
ways of doing gut so it's just by trying
to be really disciplined about it
and it's hard though because especially
once it's out there we get a lot of
suggestions from the community as you
might imagine why didn't you do this and
of course it's the most sophisticated
users who give a lot of you know did a
lot of the biggest comment I want to
avoid the pitfalls east for me I don't
know how many of you have done a lot
with Lego Mindstorms again I feel free
saying this because again i love the
Lego company we work closely with them
and they're one of the most wonderful
companies in the world I feel that when
they went from the original mindstorms
and they did a new generation of
mindstorms they were very influenced by
some of the most sophisticated users who
said what can't you add this why can't
ya that they added some great new
features but I worry about the fact that
was listening to the most sophisticated
users you know they got on the cover of
Wired magazine about all the robot
hackers who you influence the new
mindstorms in some ways that's good in
some ways that's a problem so we want to
be careful not to listen to the hackers
using scratch too much but it's a
challenge all the time because you know
people within our group we want to do
more like you know the claw one example
is you can't clone to dynamically clone
your wall projects running to make a
have a sprite you know split off a new
spreader give birth to another we'd open
up a whole new range of projects but we
haven't found a really intuitive way of
doing it we have sample projects the
sample versions that do it and everyone
you know the sophisticated users always
ask us for it but we want to wait till
we have really good ways of doing it so
oh yeah he plans to integrate scratch
with other tools so that you can I cut
grass
program thanks for that work generate
grabs baby well right now we have ways
you can you can just set you can we set
up a communication channel between
different applications a scratch can
just communicate so we have a
determinate sort of an expert feature we
can at least communicate from from
scratch to other applications so that
does certain types of control things
where scratch no sign it sends to
another applications that that's sort of
one door that allows certain types of
things otherwise we try to make it easy
for at least the output of other things
to be able to bring into obviously a lot
of the images we try to make it so it's
easier to just take the output from
other projects and drag it into scratch
so we tried to that there's probably
more that we could do to try to make it
even you know more so again we want to
do in a way that keeps it really clean
and simple so there's probably more that
we could do along the way again I guess
the main way we're doing now is setting
up this way totally sane but
communication channel and trying to make
it easy to communicate with other
applications is at least the first thing
we're starting to experiment with
another thing we might do in the next
version is this made this connects a
little bit to it as we wrote this
version the graphical programming blocks
the code for that is very much
integrated in with the rest of scratch
we want to pull it apart make them more
modular so you can take the graphical
programming blocks and use it as a
front-end to other applications because
we've seen at least it seems to us that
the visual grammar of scratch the blocks
has been very successful people really
seem to like the visual grammar that we
chose their lot there's a lot of detail
this some of it sort of looks obvious
when you look at it we went through so
many iterations and it seems to work
well so another way I think we want to
be able to interface with other types of
applications is module eyes in scratch
more so you can at least use the
programmers I have scratch and then
customize it for other you know other
applications yeah with access to so many
projects
yeah so we've done some of that of a few
different things so the few students my
group are doing that now so recent we
had one student recently was just
looking at all of the blocks used in
fact for the next version we're
eliminating some blocks because they're
used so little and we're just so we will
do some analysis of what it is what
blocks are used another thing we're
doing is certain type of analysis by age
what types of projects could done by
kids of different ages different genders
so you know things like that we're doing
analysis of this remix Inc of that sort
of the the histories of projects how
they how ideas spread through the
website those are some of the types of
things to looking at but I do think it's
a really rich source of data for doing
more so we've started to do it but I
think there's a lot more that could be
done yeah do these scratches locations
have some kind of persistence can maybe
serialize can they can it keep some kind
of context between bronze can you like
run a pull within your user and how do
you deal with security if those features
are sarah said no you can't it happen to
be a good thing to do that we'd like to
do more of that so right now there's not
a type of persistence though the
webpages persistence like the kid who
did the science experiment it collected
data but basically what it said was it
said collected to do it collected data
and then it print on the screen says
please write this in the comments below
so like the person doing the experiment
had to write the data and then the
comment space below it was persistent
but we we definitely want to do more
things like that too we've thought about
this right now we've started to
experiment like with a server-based
scratch so even doing things where
there's just this ongoing scratch world
so it's more like you know something of
some of the shared virtual world where
you can have different people you know
sharing in the world we've played around
with that a little bit or from your cell
phone phone in something to this
persistent scratch world I had one
graduate student who also did something
called with sort of net variables we
could do things where your scratch
project would grab information from the
net and we explained with
ways of having storing variables on the
scratch website so you could have your
scratch project output something they
would think it's saved on the scratch
website so we did experimental birds so
you didn't have the whole project at
save you could output some data they got
saved on the website so weeks and
actually and things like that we're
really popular the one thing we go since
I was just a research project was never
fully integrated the website but some
users find found out about it and there
are these whole threads in the
discussion forums well when is net
scratching to be available we want net
scratch and so but i judging i do think
they're lot of possibilities there and
it's just they're just too many things
to do yeah you see something Marty on
jamboree
you know five years now the money goes
away or great suit move on to other
things and
club girls who projects log in this
crashing it says 404
well the strength of a first of all I
just should have mentioned scratch was
funded by his primary the developments
primarily funded by a grant from the
National Science Foundation that ended a
year ago so so we are now dealing with
the issue of how do we continue to work
on scratch up to now we've been very
fortunate to have some supporters from
corporate supporters like Microsoft we
also funding from Intel portugal telecom
i mentioned from some foundations as
well but it's an ongoing effort to try
to continue to get you know support and
funding for it I'm deeply committed to
having this process so you know that's
one way of doing it i think it's also i
mean if i looked at the to the future if
scratch continues to grow should it can
continue to be a project run by a
research group at MIT is not obvious if
it gets big enough one options to spin
off a separate nonprofit foundation
another is to make a special
relationship with a particular company
again as we as we try scaled up just as
the website grows and grows we'd love to
be work with someone who just has a
whole you know they just can deal with
all of those things for us because we're
running all the cert we're running the
servers now so just collaborating with
someone you know perhaps we'll find a
company who has the right you know sort
of shared spirit who will sort of join
forces and to try to do it although that
doesn't you know ensure longevity you
know it eternity anyway I've one way to
ensure eternity is we're being pretty
open about it so if one type of support
doesn't happen and if it's popular
enough then hopefully there'll be other
ways of continuing to support it so I
mean right now I'm personally committed
to it my group is committed to it I can
certainly see that commitment remaining
for the next five years 10 years 15
years you know it's hard to know and but
hopefully if it's if it's successful now
if I'm popular enough then I imagine
there'll be ways to make sure that that
happens but it is an ongoing thing do we
think about it all the time yeah
yeah good question did the initial
design but we talked about a lot it was
mostly there's a core group of five of
us so for the for the first a couple
years it was five of us that did it and
we talked about this because one of the
members of the design but one of those
five says that every really good design
groupies worked with ever has always
been between four and six people says
bigger than that it just doesn't work
and so we serve kept the small there's
that core group of us that met all the
time today we and we tried to get a wide
range of group we have came from
different backgrounds and had a good
range of different abilities we're now
the group has grown and we have like
maybe a a group of ten people there's
not all full-time people there's two
full-time programmers working on it one
of them is a form once a former MIT
person once former member of our group
it was an undergrad with our group and a
master's student is now working as a
full-time programmer another is someone
that we took from alan k's group who
came to work with us and the two of them
are the main developers one of my
graduate students does most of the work
on the website he made that his master's
thesis and he manages the website
another my graduate students is doing
the scratch ed project another might
then other graduate students are doing
experiments like the scratch the scratch
for second life we hire people to do the
monitoring of the website so you know we
have a range of you know different
people doing things but right now
there's like maybe there's only two
full-time paid employees a a few half a
few part-time employees a bunch of
graduate students doing it part of their
time so for now that still works I do
worry that like with the graduate
students I can't necessary whether those
graduates will continue to be able to
spend as much time on as they have as a
question and have to make we have to
make sure this can use to be research
related to its not just a you know
keeping up the website we try to keep
research issues around it so that it
enables people to keep working on it
that way over time is it scales we hope
to collaborate with others and get more
people involved as i said before today
and this surprise you did you have an
expectation
definitely than what I said yeah Fred
students it's higher yeah yeah sounds
like a few people getting Flocka yeah
well the two people enjoyed the program
you're very very good and you know and
as you all know a few really good people
makes a huge difference and and again
there but actually almost all the code
the application is written by those two
people so yeah so get the kind of
further refine some of that yeah a
percentage of you can find any conflict
between trying to keep infrastructure of
the artifact of the work versus the
research benefits out of that and how do
you balance the between the two yeah
obviously you kept saying you need to
pull more research in so does it become
more about you know scratch taking over
the world or is it more about the
research you get out of seeing this how
people interact this ranch well it's a
combination so we're trying to make a
balance which I do I'm interested in
both of those things because i do think
i want to make a real difference in the
world and they also want to understand
you know how and what kids are learning
so i try to run my research group where
we have both of those as goals and it's
a matter of finding the right balance
and for any individual within the group
they might shift from one place to
another at different times so but yet
this hope is to do both of goose
feathers can make a real difference in
the world and for us to have a place
we're getting a better understanding of
issues so enough i have any better
answer than that okay well i know we
went on for a long time i want Thank
over i'm around for a while so pill
wanna come up yes more questions felt
right